if you were worried that since leaving
office
Donald Trump was short on grifted donor
money
I want to put to ease put to rest those
concerns Donald Trump has put nearly a
million dollars of donor money into his
own Pockets since leaving office since
leaving office this is based on a
Huffington Post analysis of a new FEC
filing Donald Trump failed to spend much
of the money he raised over the last two
years to win Georgia Senate seats or
fund the Red Wave in 2022 but he did
manage Wright's SV de te for HuffPost he
did manage to put nearly a million
dollars of his donors contributions
right back into his own cash registers
from the day he left office through the
end of 2022 the coup attempting former
president's various political committees
spent 905 thousand dollars at his
properties according to that HuffPost
analysis you don't need to even really
look at the details but when you do you
find hundred thousand dollars in hotel
spending here four hundred thousand
dollars in Camp in hotel spending there
Trump Tower rent offices all of these
different things now the reality is that
even this number of a million dollars
doesn't fully represent the degree to
which Donald Trump is funneling donor
money back into his own Pockets there's
actually a lot of different ways that
this is done one way of course is by
raising donor money and then having
campaign or pack spending be spent at
your own businesses another way is to
pay off your own campaign debts even
when you claim to to be raising money
for something different there are so
many different ways that you can funnel
money that is being donated for
political reasons
uh back back into your own Pockets you
can also use your personal properties
and have foreign dignitaries who visit
you as so many did and stayed at Trump's
DC Hotel uh in order to ingratiate
themselves with you by staying at your
hotel which of course makes you money
while you are President of the United
States there's all of these different
ways that you can do it what we know is
that it is a grift and a scam all the
way down and if Republican voters want
him to he's going to do it again in
2024. we will stay on the finance story
because it's really as big a story as
any of the other stuff the finance grift
scam that Trump has now run for six
years is extraordinary and he's getting
away with it at least for now all of the
clips I played here will be on our
YouTube channel find it at youtube.com
slashed the David Pacman show make sure
you're subscribed
let's talk about plastic 100 billion
plastic bags are used and thrown away
each year huge contributor to plastic
waste you might think there's no way
around it think again our sponsor hold
on bags makes trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based and non-toxic so they break
down in weeks rather than decades and
they don't fill up our landfills or
pollute our oceans hold on zip seal
kitchen bags come in sandwich or gallon
sizes for all of your needs and because
they are plant-based hold on trash bags
and their zip seal kitchen bags are 100
percent home compostable so what I do is
I put my food garbage in a hold on bag
throw the whole thing into the compost
pile it's fantastic but even for
everyday garbage I'm putting in the
dumpster there is something really
simple and easy I can do to make a
difference just to save plastic to shop
plant-based bags and replace single-use
Plastics all over your home go to holdon
bags.com Pacman use the code Pacman for
twenty percent off the link is down
below